hola nos dicen cada tarde carolina se va
en bicicleta desde la escuela hasta su
casa ella deja la escuela a las 1455 y
llega a casa a las 1525 cuánto tiempo
anda en bicicleta pausa el vídeo como
siempre e intenta responder la pregunta
cuánto tiempo anda en bicicleta ok te
ayudaré a responderla para eso voy a
colocar una línea de tiempo esta es mi
línea de tiempo y veamos todo transcurre
entre las 14 horas y pasando las 15
horas así que iré hasta las 16 horas
aquí tengo las 14 horas por acá las 15
horas y por acá las 16 horas por acá
tenemos las 14 30 horas solo para hacer
las cosas más claras y por acá tenemos
las 15 30
justo así y veamos ella deja la escuela
a las 1455 donde se encuentra es ahora
en mi línea de tiempo bueno 1455 es
cinco minutos antes de las 15 horas así
que será aproximadamente por aquí a esta
hora carolina deja la escuela aquí son
las 1455 después ella llega a las 1525
eso es 25 minutos después de las 15
horas así que será justo aquí justo aquí
a las 15 25 es cuando ella llega a casa
cuánto tiempo es esto
bueno la forma de pensarlo es ir de las
1455 a las 15 horas
eso es 5 minutos esta parte de aquí son
5 minutos y después de las
15 horas a las 1525 son otros 25 minutos
así que en total la duración de su viaje
en bicicleta va a ser de 5 minutos + 25
minutos 5 + 25 es 30 así que 30 minutos
30 minutos y hemos acabado